come to this video and play my old
nemesis only gas from Latvia and for a
change I'm playing e4 let's see him want
to try something else against the guy I
recently have have had a look at this
and decided that it can be played with
white at some point leading to a very
very solid position and yeah we know
he's one of my is my my nemesis really I
have for three points out of 14 and in
blitz games against him without any win
which is which is the the most
remarkable thing about it not winning
any game is is quite quite quite
remarkable okay we have a very
simplified position but it's still very
young very comfortable for white I'm
really making a conscious effort here
not to fall too far behind on the clock
very equal endgame
hmm I'm going to play b3 and I guess I
don't want to spend ages here try to
stay on an even level on the clock
maybe this is the the right the right
recipe
it's gaining gaining some space him I
don't think it's it's anything serious
though and I can also play Bishop f5 at
any point Jack trade this off check
yeah it looks active for the black but
there's not much happening
the time is about equal
hmm yeah what about the night the trade
here in 91 bishop chief forum but
there's a double attack
no cannot do that really okay then I
must take that's not really great
it's fairly uncomfortable I did okay on
the clock but and not position wise what
I'm trying to do is play ninety two and
then before it's still not apparent to
me how he should win this but it's clear
that I have allowed some things I can
maybe if I go before something I takes
takes a four and then enter with the
king this is maybe possible
maybe
I have some Zook spawn problems anyway
my I mean I cannot move the King really
because of III I pretty much must play
before there's this chick coming with
then III maybe you know came I really
don't have much choice I must do that
basically takes takes a form is the
critical continuation this is not
critical I think
hmm but how do you how do you play that
though I just stay here on a1 how do I
lose it get out of the go out of this
check you need to try to attack the
pawns for you three times it's pretty
easy turn off
can I check a force somehow I could have
played night aged firefighters got King
you fight that that's that's problematic
check
check
okay so I can draw now we're taking
twice Jack okay game drive so at least a
draw against my favorite opponent I had
no chance really to to play on time
myself in which I will would do against
him with every sort of position because
I mean it's completely yeah
don't elaborate on that further I wanted
to play it safe but still managed to get
into into some trouble here
Jack I was I was really in the in the
words end game but yeah I think it was
quite surprising that that he just
captured twice because I think this
should really be a draw it looks it
looks it's passive and everything but I
thought he should try this and then try
to enter I was thinking that this should
win the game it looked very dangerous to
me the b-pawn is stopped by the bishop
hmm not clear computer is on minus 1.5
but I'm not totally totally convinced by
the evaluation simply because the
computers also in the game is also on -
one point something no no it goes down
to zero point seven yeah I really think
this should be a draw with the King only
one it is very fortress like something
if he goes to e3 but with the pawn for
example I can also always just stay and
do nothing and it's very hard to mean to
engineer some some sort of breakthrough
and King D 2 was possible I can just
Jack can just shuffle with the night
there is there is nothing to do here of
course it's totally dead
yeah not exciting but I simply want to
score something against him managed
managed to draw it wouldn't I don't know
how to do that okay thanks for watching